David Cameron never actually said he'd
hugger hoodie and no it's inconceivable
that he would in response to the rights
the Prime Minister has signaled a new
zero-tolerance approach to speak plain
the idea that if more level criminality
such as graffiti of smashed windows is
ignored tolerated by the police of the
community there's greater risk of more
serious offenders
even the politician who labeled the
Conservatives the nasty party sees
merits and a far more robust approach
I've talked to officers who were on the
streets at Salford I've talked to
officers who are on the streets in
Tottenham in Clapham and what was clear
from those officers brave officers out
there facing these thugs dealing with
this criminality was that they wanted to
ensure that they could get tough that
they could take a tough approach to the
people who they saw destroying local
communities as the riots raged sordid
senior officers stung by criticism did
not reacted quickly more vigorously
enough and then shifting to zero
tolerance policing the politicians are
again signaling their discontent with
the way street cone is policed the
appointments of American super cop Bill
Bratton as government adviser Rob's yet
more salt and wound the government seems
to be an importing best practice what
they're considered to be a better
practice from the USA when in fact we've
got a wealth of experience and knowledge
within our own Police Service and we
believe that that we should call upon
that first zero tolerance policing is
intensive visible policing bobbies on my
feet centre whose 16,000 will be lost to
the cuts the Metropolitan Police were
clearly overstretched in the early
stages of the writing
how can you get tougher if you've been
able to turn over on the case I make to
government and I'm going to continue to
make is that numbers matter and I think
that the numbers we got on the streets
of London now they're up on when I came
in but it's vital that we keep them high
and that we keep public others people
need to see police out there on accused
of a lack of leadership as London burns
the politicians are desperate to offer
public submissions yet there is no a
disconnect between the police and their
political masters which if left to
fester places at risk the response if
the unthinkable happens and they ride
again
near paterson Sky News